You just clicked on this video, meaning you're alive
It is interesting that in order to know where you came from
We must first understand what it means
To be alive. Life is organized
A genetic unit that can be metabolized
Reproduction and evolution. It is important
Remember this, when we go back in time to find out exactly how I came here
Astronomers believe that our solar system has begun
Formed 4.6 million years ago, when a star exploded
And falling to form the sun
And about 500 similar planets interconnected
To form the soles of the planets
And for about 600 million years
The land was very hot to live, and most of the water was
Evaporates through space, even if some chemicals are simple and reacted
And began to take up a living space
Comets and meteorites collided with Earth at the time
They have brought in enough heat to develop the ocean floor
Destroying all possibilities of life. And until comets and meteorites subsided
The earth cooled and it became possible for the water to stay on the surface.
Thus, life began about 3.7 million years ago.
I found many theories about how
Which began quite well, some believe in simple life
Which came from a meteorite, while others believe that chemical evolution
He began with interactive vehicles reacting with the heat
Or perhaps struck by lightning
It is difficult to identify, a new study claims to be obtained
On the oldest fossil, over 3.77 million years old
An old microbe has evolved
Near an outlet for thermal venting in the ocean floor
At that time, simple cells began to develop
On the ground, they were able to confine energy, and multiply
And evolution, to become the only unit
Which created this life, which includes you.
And for two millennia, all living creatures on Earth are single-celled
They probably lived in the oceans
Preserved from ultraviolet rays
But then something remarkable happened
Photosynthesis.
Before 2.5 billion years ago, there was a random surge
They were useful for cells, and they started using solar energy to boost their food representation.
And since then, oxygen, or O
It was the product of photosynthesis, changing our atmosphere
Thereby renewing the ozone layer that represented the protection of the Earth
From the deadly rays of the sun, and of course at this point
Oxygen is toxic to most living organisms
But over time, cells evolved to its potential, and because of metabolism
And its interaction with oxygen, it became effective, and cells can grow more.
And about a billion years later
Cells began to merge smaller cells
Their ability to live in a variety of environments has increased.
This selective feature led to the intertwining of cells together in a coordinated manner
Even after the split, these cells in the end
I began to exchange genetic specimens
They have had sex. Individual organizations will be divided by equal division
Or through simplified atomic division, however
When hemispheric evolution developed, genetic reorganization began to emerge
The rate of development is increasing as production
Whenever they are genetically modified, and some of them
The probability of living and procreation was greater
So, the tree of life began to explode,
At first there were plants, and then fungi, corals and then amphibians such as crabs
Skin prickles like sea urchins, and then fish
Such as sharks and cod fish, and then the quartets evolved from fish
To begin partly by adapting to living outside the water
Initially inhalation of air and absorption of oxygen in the gastrointestinal tract.
Over time, primates will develop separate lungs
Of the gastrointestinal tract to absorb oxygen, and a new way of walking on land as well
And then amphibians and reptiles
Dinosaurs and, finally, mammals.
In fact, the trunk of our entire origins comes from the tail of a furry rat, like mammals
Which survived and flourished, 66 million years ago
Just after the cocoon that removed the dinosaurs.
And after decades of development
To glorify another species, another branch of the family tree
Evolved into a monkey and a full line of monkeys. And for nearly 4 million years, one of the first
Human-like creatures arrived,
The most famous antiquities are attributed to (Lucy) who stood straight
For previous generations
Before 100,000 or 2-3 million years ago, set primate
She started and had a bigger brain
And began to use their hands for several complex activities such as construction
And the use of tools. This was the first step to transformation
Our environment to improve our lives.
It was also a catalyst for the transition from plant diet
For others containing meat
This is an intensive method of nutrition, less affected by seasonal shortages.
These simple stone tools enable us to cut meat
It may become the instrument chosen for two million years.
And for about 1.8 million years, human phenomenon
Popped up, the immediate predecessor of our faction.
And finally, a few hundred thousand years ago, modern humans
Or human wise, step towards light.
Larger, smarter, and more capable than his predecessors
Interestingly, we almost
We did not make it a changing environment until 140,000 years ago
The human population was reduced to only hundreds of people
Objects threatened, but we survived.
As recently as 60,000 years ago
Three different factions of the "human" family coexisted.
Homo neanderthalensis homo denisova
We, the wise man, have all lived together on this planet
In fact, sane and neanderthalensis often mated
That's why most modern humans, including you
They have nuclear neanderthalensis acid. neanderthalensis died years ago
When 30,000 of the mortals arrived
To what is now "Europe" and from this point
Humans were the only beings living on Earth.
Unlike our principal relatives, who favored their own development
While our evolution chose the power of reason and in fact
Your mind weighs 2% of your body weight
But it uses 20% of your calories. And this power of mind
Has enabled us to survive in a variety of environments
Where we began to travel around the world.
Wherever we started we were small groups of less than 100
We have settled into groups of thousands, millions and billions.
You were born
So, how did you get here. Autrjim @